ils sont nombreux à avoir fait des
blagues à propos de son nom mais il en
faut beaucoup plus pour déranger mas
candille 11 octobre
mc candle vivait son baptême de la lna
ce réaliste oui car il ya à peine deux
ans et demi personne ne s'intéressait à
lui à celui qui venait de terminer son
stage à la prestigieuse université
princeton et qui n'a jamais été repêché
non mais d'écran assez pour qu'il
considère une autre avenue wall street
un stage d'une journée dans le domaine
de la finance qui l'a convaincu que ce
n'était pas pour lui c'est un essai en
californie dans la east coast league qui
a été le déclencheur camden a su tirer
le maximum de chaque petite chance et
faire son chemin jusqu'au camp des
espoirs avec le canadien puis à un
contrat en mai 2013
je m'occupe estime qu'en donne puis à il
m'a impressionné premier cannes et
prospects du pij et je l'avais mais
j'avais cru andré adore ce concentre sur
les bonnes choses soient laissés
influencer par sur certaines choses
ips idées afin que j'ai l'impression
qu'ils savaient déjà parce que maicon
d'une a travaillé fort à ne plus analysé
pendant ses matches depuis quelques
années il s'est initié à la méditation
et à la visualisation positive
parce que naisse assemblée quelques
années et puis elle est accompagnée des
choses la ned par la façon qui a pour
hashtag et on comprend aussi son ardeur
quand il nous parle de son père solide
dans sa tête solide devant le filet de
départ deux victoires pour mike en 2006
diane sauvé radio canada montréal